bonne nouvelle alors faut quand même
donner de l'espoir l'année est finie la
mauvaise c'est que vu ce que nous attend
vous risquez de la regretter l'année de
ne pas
j'accueille maintenant elle est pas
belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
copain de la Saint Sylvestre couillons
du réveillon bonsoir
bienvenue dans cette chronique
transitoire entre deux agapes qui sans
doute vous mettre le foie dans un tel
état que si on commercialisé du foie
gras d'homme et bien ce serait la bonne
période pour vous abattre
chance nous habitons dans un pays aux
normes sanitaire très strict ou les
religions s'accordent à dire que l'homme
est trop sale pour être halal
très accent pourri qui n'apporte rien
d'autre que juste vous dire que je parle
aussi des langues tribales
ah qu'il fait bon d'être né au dessus de
la Loire
cette année donc ces restrictions à tous
les étages avec des proches on est allés
au Resto du Coeur bon après du casse
parce qu'on voulait atterrir
tranquillement quand même et on a fait
une action de sensibilisation au bon
goût des gens un peu d'émane enfin des
gens un peu plus moins équipés
financièrement
alors on l'a fait un test alors dans la
soupe moulinée qui servent on a fait
deux groupes à un groupe on a servi de
la vraie truffe et un autre à placer
beau c'est à dire des petits bouts de
pneus crevés
et ben crois-le ou pas les clients
réclamaient le placer
[Applaudissements]
parce qu'il disait
ça leur appelait vachement plus le
terroir
bref pour ce trou normand entre de
remonter acide j'aimerais vous rappeler
que vous avez peut-être déjà oublié des
choses qui sont passées en 2013 une
année précaire normale 64 millions de
personnes sur un pédalo motorisé par les
mollets de René Coty bon ben c'est plus
de la navigation c'est l'exploration des
abysses une année coulée bon ce sont des
événements et des hommes il y a des
hommes qui font des événements il y a
des événements qui font les hommes puis
à François Hollande qui fait ah bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est c'est évidemment l'homme
incontournable cette année on ne peut
pas il y a pas de Godi possible
souvenez-vous déjà ça commençait
générale en chef au Mali il pète une
durite il envahit le Mali et il a appelé
l'opération militaire l'opération Serval
alors le serval je rappelle c'est un
petit félin qui a la particularité de
pisser 30 fois en une heure pour marquer
son territoire
comme quoi être intronisé sous la pluie
ça marque un ça donne un style quoi
la guerre on l'a gagné
c'était un peu prévisible elle passe
faire démonter par des mecs qui savent
pas faire une carte UNICEF
autre sujet le mariage pour tous quel
polémique quel polémique je me souviens
de cette blague qui d'un député qui
faisait les marchés le dimanche qui
disait mais vous savez le chômage nous
on lutte les gens qui disaient
occupe-toi plutôt du mariage gay
d'ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
moi en tout cas à l'époque j'étais
extrêmement choqué par certains slogans
vraiment nauséabond lui il y en avait
intérêt c'était zéro maman c'est
déprimant
on voit qu'ils connaissent pas mal
je veux dire ma mère en termes
d'optimisme welbecq c'est un géo du Club
Med
paria de l'année 2013 Jérôme Cahuzac
Cahuzac qui était décrit comme l'un des
meilleurs du gouvernement mais il
mentait il mentait que
Cahuzac a laissé une lettre dans
laquelle il s'est dit dévasté par le
remord dévasté ah c'est sûr s'il avait
placé un peu plus de fréquence Suisse
sur le peut-être pas eu besoin de
revenir en France qui ont été
fashion victime de l'année Clément Méric
militant d'extrême gauche
anticapitaliste qui met au cours d'une
vente privée pourquoi pas négationniste
qui décède dans une chambre à gaz
femme de l'année Taubira quand même on
se rattrape taubirac a déclaré que la
prison forme la délinquance c'est vrai
en gros pour paraphraser Rousseau tous
les délinquants naissent bon c'est la
prison qui les rend mauvais
non mais
c'est vrai que la prison c'est peut-être
pas la solution idéale pour un
délinquant en revanche pour le voisinage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
le groupe de l'année n'en déplaise à
Laurent voulzyle et to be free étant
dissout les Spice Girls à la retraite
cette année c'est le groupe les Roms qui
ont fait le buzz
ouais dans la section au cuivre ils sont
imbattables
[Applaudissements]
on en a on en a beaucoup parlé les Roms
les rhums les Roms et c'est vrai que
toutes ces polémiques un moment on se
pose une question pourquoi est-ce qu'on
les stigmatise tellement parce que ça
fait du bien
prostitution autre sujet majeur alors il
y a une loi qui a été votée donc
maintenant les clients seront désormais
pénalisés de 1500 euros ou du double
s'il récidive et ben oui quand on pense
qu'une pipe coûte 20 euros là il sera
1520 euros c'est-à-dire la fille elle va
se donner tu vois
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Kennedy avait Marilyn Hollande à
leonarda
le routard de l'année les otages oui qui
sont rentrés et qui ils ont eu de la
chance dans leur malheur vu le niveau
des impôts pour eux fiscalement c'était
une année blanche
ah oui
destination touristique de l'année
Lampedusa petite
île des côtes italienne cette Corse qui
ne dépassons non pas une île tellement
attractive que les touristes sont prêts
à venir à la nage
[Applaudissements]
bonne nouvelle alors faut quand même
donner de l'espoir l'année finie la
mauvaise c'est que vu ce que nous attend
vous risquez de la regretter l'année
2013 alors ma belle la vie et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de inarritube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu